RICK KLEFFEL: Ladies and
gentlemen, we are privileged
to have a man who has a habit
of seeing the future of
America, writing a book about
it, and telling us where we're
going to be in about five years,
when we don't know it's
already happened.
He did so--
god--
longer ago than I would care to
admit, when he gave us all
"The Electric Kool-Aid Acid
Test." He did it again when he
told us just what was "The Right
Stuff." He did it again,
when he said, "I Am Charlotte
Simmons."
Now he's back again.
He's one of America's
best authors.
He's a man who has seen the
future and the present.
It's Tom Wolfe.
His new book is "Back
to Blood." Thank you
for joining me, Tom.
TOM WOLFE: You're welcome.
And if you'd really like to see
a vision of the future, go
to my website.
It's called Analog.
You'll have radios again that
you can adjust the volume by
just turning.
Didn't anybody ever
see that before?
You turn a wheel.
It's very handy.
But I'm not going to--
I have a feeling it
may not even go.
RICK KLEFFEL: One of the things
that struck me as I
read this book was that, in
fact, this is something you do
have a habit of doing.
Is finding out what America's
really about, and going there,
and telling us two
stories at once.
How America got that way, in the
midst of a thrilling story
about characters we
really care about.
And I'm wondering, what took you
to Miami to show us this
particular vision of America?
TOM WOLFE: I was really
interested in immigration.
And this was at a time when
most of the immigration
stories-- and sometimes they
were great stories-- about how
people got in to the
United States.
But that had been
done to death.
And I was curious about
what did immigrants do
once they were here.
And I was first interested in
the Vietnamese in California,
who, for the most part, I guess,
are still in the Los
Angeles region.
But I then saw that the San
Jose Mercury, which is
northern California, has a
second edition, which is
called the Viet Mercury.
I really would like to get
to know the Vietnamese.
Then I discovered I can't speak
the language, and I
can't even begin to read
the Viet Mercury.
But I was interested
in immigration.
And people say, what are
you interested in now?
And I'd say, well, I'm
interested in immigration.
And they'd say, oh
that's great.
And then their heads
would fall off.
They'd go to sleep like
a horse, standing up.
But I had faith in
that subject.
And then I heard about Miami.
Of course, I'd heard of Miami
before, but not in connection
to immigration.
Miami is really immigration
central for the United States.
It's the only city--
I think it's the only city in
the world, as far as I know--
in which more than half the
population is recent
immigrants, many within
the last 50 years.
And people from another
country, with another
language, and another culture
politically, control this vast
metropolitan area of Miami.
Of course, I'm talking
about the Cubans.
It's interesting, just
how unusual that is.
Russians are coming in in
great numbers right now.
And they tend to live where
Miami Beach joins the
mainland, north of
South Beach.
I consider this book
are great triumph.
It hardly mentions South
Beach at all.
Very few contemporary books
on Miami do that.
And realizing that I really knew
nothing about Miami, I
still thought it was a tourist
resort, I decided the only way
to find out just to go there.
And I had good luck.
There was a former journalist
for the Miami Herald, a second
generation Cuban named Oscar
Corral, wrote me out of the
blue, and said, I think you'll
find it interesting here.
And so I went.
And I find if you can
get along with--
Oscar is great-- but if you can
get along with one person
for five hours anywhere you go,
that first will probably
introduce you to
somebody else.
And it goes from there.
A, I never tried to report
in a white suit.
Everbody would say, hey!
Tom Wolfe is here!
Talk to me.
I wear a blue blazer.
But come to think of it,
I guess I do stand out,
because I have a--
anybody here know
what this is?
[LAUGHTER]
RICK KLEFFEL: Polka dot tie.
TOM WOLFE: Right, a tie.
There are parts of America
where these are unknown.
I just discovered
them recently.
And if anybody would like them,
I'll tell you my supplier.
[LAUGHTER]
TOM WOLFE: Anyway.
RICK KLEFFEL: Now Tom, one of
the things that struck me
about reading this book, and
thinking of all your other
books going back, is that before
there was a Google,
your books were designed to be
read by somebody who has
Google to hand, to summon up.
To go, oh my god.
Could that really be true?
They're filled with these kind
of details that call out their
attention to us.
I'd like to talk about some of
the finding those kind of real
life details, and putting them
in your fiction, and putting
them in your nonfiction, and
telling a story with these
great little bits.
And also, did you use
Google when you were
writing this book?
TOM WOLFE: Oh my god.
I'm one out of eight billion,
I think, who do use Google.
Think of all the times
I didn't go
New York Public library.
I sat home.
I have to ask, though,
about Google.
When I look things up, I've
learned more about ornithology
by using Google all the time.
You can always recognize
the dove--
it's flying through
a commercial--
it has a staggered flight.
And even swans taking off.
I've seen a lot of swans.
They can take off very,
very rapidly.
There are other things to learn,
other than the facts
that you're looking for.
And it's very attractive
to see these birds.
RICK KLEFFEL: So you're one of
the many authors who find
Google to be something of a
mixed blessing, in that it
offers you--
TOM WOLFE: Oh, no.
It's not mixed it all.
I learn about other things.
RICK KLEFFEL: So you--
TOM WOLFE: Birds.
Anyway, I'm not comfortable
with something I'm writing
about, even in a novel.
Until I was 57 years old, I
wrote nothing but nonfiction.
So I paid my dues in
nonfiction work.
And it was fun, because at
that time, things were
happening in nonfiction that
hadn't happened before.
I still think, probably the--
I shouldn't say this.
Here's the way you
get around it.
You really want to praise
somebody highly, you say, he's
one of the two.
Then all the other writers can
say, oh yeah, I was the other.
Anyway, I think Michael Lewis,
who's a nonfiction writer, is
one of the two greatest writers
in America today.
I'm not saying that for
my own benefit.
He's fabulous.
He knows how to tell a
story in nonfiction.
Which is actually not
all that hard.
There are just four devices that
can make nonfiction sound
like the most gripping novel
you've ever read.
One is scene-by-scene
construction.
So instead of going from a scene
to some long essay about
something or other, you go to
another scene, and another
scene, and another scene.
The second is extensive
dialogue.
You can't always get that.
When I wrote a book on
astronauts, I really wasn't
there when John Glenn made
the first orbital trip.
But two things helped.
One, astronauts at that time
had to go through detailed
question and answer sessions,
because at the time, NASA did
not know what they were
going to find.
And I talked them into
declassifying those.
RICK KLEFFEL: Really?
TOM WOLFE: Yes.
They started scratching their
heads, well, I don't know why
we keep these declassified.
Also, I use something that I
call the downstage voice.
If you're really stymied
for accurate--
and even in writing
a novel, I want
this stuff to be accurate--
you could write in the third
person narrative as if you're
a voice of someone or some
typical character in the book.
At one point, I was writing
about Junior Johnson, a stock
car driver.
And he's in a practice
run around the
North Wilkesboro Raceway.
And he was the fastest
driver that was in
NASCAR at the time.
And so I suddenly say, "great
smokin' blue gumballs!
There goes Junior Johnson!"
That was to indicate the
excitement that he created.
And it was me speaking.
It wasn't anybody
in the scene.
That's a helpful thing.
Dialogue is the most readable
form of prose that there is.
And you can go on and on in
dialogue, and in long
sentences, anything.
People will still find
it easy to read.
Now, the movies can do both of
those things better than the
written word.
Scene-by-scene construction
and dialogue.
But there are two things the
written word does better than
anything that has yet
been invented.
I signed all these releases
that said that you'd give
whoever it is right for every
device they can think of, and
it says "and anything invented
in the future." Well, suppose
there's some sexual apparatus
you read by.
I don't want be--
I almost crossed that out.
I don't want to be involved
in that kind of stuff.
[LAUGHTER]
TOM WOLFE: Anyway, notation
of status details.
Movies cannot handle that.
I'll give an example.
I don't what the hot
loafers are today.
But it was Gucci loafers.
They were expensive.
They were considered
high class.
But you can show on the screen
a pair of Gucci loafers--
RICK KLEFFEL: Nobody's
going to know what
the hell they are.
TOM WOLFE: Yeah.
They want to know why that
camera's lingering on those
dumb pair of shoes.
They have a golden crossbar
that links in the middle.
But in writing, it's nothing
to point these things out.
And in the Godfather, when they
want to show that this
one character-- he's not
a mafia character--
one character is decadent.
They have him living in a house
that would have made the
Borgias shrink.
Oh my god, look at
the size of that.
And there's a famous scene,
where they cut off the head of
one of his race horses.
And they sneak into the room
while he's asleep, and they
put it on the bed, so that he'll
wake up, and he'll see
his great thoroughbred head
at the foot of the bed.
But to let you know he's
decadent, they have to get him
silk salmon-colored sheets,
a bed that you could play
soccer, and with every
sort of trimming.
In writing, you do not have
to go to all that trouble.
As I say that 98% of life is
concerned, for everybody, with
status, as I call it.
RICK KLEFFEL: Class.
And that's a big part
of this book.
TOM WOLFE: Even people doing
things that are absolutely
solitary, like going
to the bat-room.
I used to call it
the bat-room.
At home, with family, I just
say, I've got to go check on
the Batmobile.
What are you talking about?
It's in the bat-room.
Anyway, that's child talk.
I'm sorry.
Just think about it some time.
The things that you do in total
privacy of any kind that
you do because of your idea of
where this puts you in the
social order.
And it doesn't mean you want to
rise in the social order.
I grew up in the South,
and I've known a
lot of good old boys.
I really have.
And they don't realize how they
think they're dressing
really casually.
But they all dress casually
the same way.
The big overalls, and the
clodhoppers, and there was a
kind of t-shirt, really the
worst kind of plaid shirt you
could possibly buy.
RICK KLEFFEL: Now, Tom.
What's the fourth way that you
were going to tell us?
TOM WOLFE: The fourth
is you're going
to write every scene--
we've got scenes going here--
from the point of view
of one person.
And for example, when I was
writing "The Electric Kool-Aid
Acid Test"-- which took me into
these parts quite often--
because of the reporting I'd
done, I had some scenes where
some information was given to
me by this person, and other
information was given to
me by that person.
And so I would be inside
of their heads.
It's written in the
third person.
But as a novelist, constantly
you're inside somebody's head,
watching what's going on.
It's a very effective device.
It's a controversial device.
But I think, if you had been
with a person long enough, and
you really trust them to the
extent that they are telling
you the truth, not just piping
up, I think it's worth using.
In "The Electric Pool Acid
Test," people wondered, well,
why is this whole section in
Sandy Lehmann-Haupt's name?
Oh, and this part is in Mountain
Girl's frame of mind.
And that was because I didn't
have information from
everybody for all these
different scenes.
But I still think it--
Sandy Lehmann-Haupt,
for example--
Sandy won't mind because
this was already
published in the book--
had had a lot of troubles
with schizophrenia
and things like that.
And drugs like LSD--
which, incidentally, was
invented by academics because
it was thought to mimic the
symptoms of schizophrenia.
So you start taking a little
of that, and you're already
troubled, and life becomes--
RICK KLEFFEL: Challenging.
TOM WOLFE: Challening.
It does.
Everything, I insist--
and nobody listens--
in fiction or nonfiction
is reporting.
You cannot make up what
goes on in this world.
You cannot.
RICK KLEFFEL: So that means you
didn't make up the Pissing
Monkey syndrome, which is
something that I had to look
up on Google.
So tell us about the Pissing
Monkey syndrome, and the part
it plays in this book.
TOM WOLFE: I didn't go check
it out in terms of science.
But one of the characters
tells about this.
He's a psychiatrist.
I guess he's telling
what he knows.
I don't know if any of you--
I never have-- have ever
had a pet monkey?
A pet male monkey.
If you're are male, and
you have gotten this
pet into your home--
in particular something like a
spider monkey, which are small
but very agile--
that monkey, that little
male monkey, will start
pissing on your head.
[LAUGHTER]
TOM WOLFE: This to
show dominance.
You'll be sleeping.
And I don't know how he gets up
to the overhead light, but
it's pissing on you.
And if you try to make up to the
monkey with good things to
eat, and a lot of stroking
and all this stuff, it
only makes it worse.
You're obviously a pushover.
[LAUGHTER]
TOM WOLFE: A real chump.
And you get drenched
day and night.
You're just getting dressed,
getting ready to have some
meeting to go, and psssshhhh!
The only thing that works is to
seize the monkey, and throw
him in the toilet, and
flush the toilet.
And at first, he'll yell,
kind of like a Eeee!
Eeee!
But when he gets down to Eeh.
Eeh.
Ehh.
You know you've won.
And now you have outpissed
him with this machine.
He doesn't know where
it's coming from.
And after that, he couldn't
be nicer.
And this comes into
play in this book.
RICK KLEFFEL: It's one of
those things that you're
probably going to only
find on Google.
Tom, this is a kind
of a raunchy book.
And one of the most incredible
scenes that you unfurl is the
Columbus Day Regatta.
Did you go to a Columbia Day--
TOM WOLFE: I did.
RICK KLEFFEL: --Regatta?
TOM WOLFE: Yeah.
RICK KLEFFEL: Oh my god.
And it's a real thing?
TOM WOLFE: It's a real thing.
A Columbus Day Regatta is a
sailboat race in Biscayne Bay.
And I guess the Atlantic
comes in there.
It's from one key, the name
of which I do not know, to
another, which is called
Elliott Key.
Elliott Key is a state park, but
there's almost nothing on
it to recommend it, other than
the Columbus Day Regatta.
When this Regatta started,
it was serious sailors.
Afterwards, they would always
have a party on Elliott Key.
And this party was,
apparently, a
great little party.
And people who were not involved
in racing at all
would come out, and they'd
join the party.
And it got bigger and
it got bigger.
And when I went, and when the
people from the last 15 years
went, nobody had a clue as
to who won the race.
They still have the race.
Nobody knew the name
of a boat.
Nobody had even saw one.
They were there for the party.
And it gradually became an
astounding orgy in which, for
example, pornographic movies are
shown on schooner sails.
Schooner sails are bigger
than other sails.
And we're talking
real hardcore.
Things that you might
think of as--
I won't say the numbers, but--
[LAUGHTER]
TOM WOLFE: --six by
two, let's say.
If you're lucky.
Are 6 and 1/2 feet long, and
they're wide enough to walk
through it.
There was a door.
And it goes.
And at first it's weird.
You can't tell exactly
what orifice of the
human body is opening.
They're all so big.
You expect to see an explorer
walk into one of these.
RICK KLEFFEL: It sounds like
the ship in alien.
TOM WOLFE: Well, it's
alien, all right.
And then there are always-- and
this is a great feature of
Columbus Day Regatta--
the nude waterski crowd.
Mostly girls without
at stitch on.
And people will watch
that for hours.
Watching them go by.
And they always smile
toward the audience.
And there's a--
Well, I won't go into this.
But there's some males who make
it worth your attention
to be viewed.
They'll take 14, 15, I'd even
say 20 boats, lashed together,
to create one gigantic deck.
Of course it's a kind
of up and down deck.
But it becomes one big party.
And in fact, after a while it
kind of gets dangerous,
because everybody's drunk, that
they don't really look
out for these little boat
going around, too.
And then finally, there are
people who get laid into, and
they're just having
at it on the deck.
It caught my attention.
[LAUGHTER]
RICK KLEFFEL: It sounds like
very definitely a difficult
feat of journalism to go
uncover such an even.
TOM WOLFE: Well, you have
to pay the price.
Anyway.
And one of my characters is a
psychiatrist whose specialty
is treating pornography
addiction.
Which is a bigger problem than
most people realize.
This is hard to believe.
But about one half of all the
hits on the internet are
pornographic.
Just think about that.
And often--
RICK KLEFFEL: We are at a
monument to such hits, to a
certain degree.
TOM WOLFE: It wouldn't
happen here.
RICK KLEFFEL: What's the Frank
Zappa line? "It can't happen
here."
TOM WOLFE: And the real toll
it's taken on business people,
who get this addiction.
They're afraid to
do it at home.
They can't find any
sanctuary at home.
So more and more, the business
day, nine to five, is take--
Don't anybody kid you.
What always accompanies male
pornography watching is
masturbation.
And even the coarsest bureaucrat
doesn't really want
to be seen doing this.
RICK KLEFFEL: That's not an
image-enhancing experience.
TOM WOLFE: So he has to
go somewhere else.
He's leaving the business
to that extent.
Oh, the pissing monkey got
into that, because the
psychiatrist, the one who told
about the pissing monkey.
RICK KLEFFEL: Well, it's a
natural progression from
pissing monkeys to
pornography.
TOM WOLFE: In general, though,
I just found that if you just
keep looking.
And I think if you just settle
in for 30 days, anywhere in
the United States, you're going
to see something that
you could not have imagined,
and something that would be
interesting to the
general public.
Part of that's because, despite
the crash of 2008,
this is still a rich country
compared to any other country
in the world.
And people now have the
money to express
themselves in some way.
Las Vegas, for example, the
Strip and all that, was built
by gangsters.
And their idea of a great
resort was Miami.
So Las Vegas happened to be
in the Mojave Desert.
But the first great hotel built
there was called The
Flamingo, because that's what
they have in Florida.
And the interesting part
about that is not
that they're gangsters.
It's that they never finished
high school.
I've never heard of a member of
the mafia who ever finished
high school.
Don't tell anybody
I said that.
I've never heart--
RICK KLEFFEL: You know, it's
going out on YouTube, so--
TOM WOLFE: Oh yeah,
that's right.
I never heard one.
And so we are talking about
creators from a stratum of
society that creators never
came from before.
And they really did create
the modern Las Vegas.
Another example of just the
wealth of this country--
every year, the state of North
Carolina, when the cotton
crops are due, brings in
10,000 so-called guest
workers, mostly from Mexico,
because there's not a living
native-born North Carolinian of
any origin whatsoever who
will pick cotton anymore.
People would rather sit on the
corner with a hatful of
pencils than to pick cotton.
It's the worst work
in the world.
I joined a niece of mine
for about 10 minutes.
That was all it was for
my cotton picking.
It's in the hottest weather
you can imagine.
The cotton balls have all
these prickly ends.
Oh, and Sparta, North Carolina,
which I wrote about
a novel called "I Am Charlotte
Simmons." Sparta is in the
Blue Ridge mountains
of North Carolina.
It's too hilly to grow crops.
It's impossible, except
for one crop--
Christmas trees.
And probably a third of the
Christmas trees in America
come from Sparta,
North Carolina.
I was on farms--
they call them farms--
of Christmas trees that were
going to be 500,000 Christmas
trees growing in one place.
It takes about 12 years
for them to mature.
But every year, at least once,
sometimes twice, somebody has
to cut that Christmas tree in
the shape of a Christmas tree.
Otherwise, it's going to
be a great big bush.
And the way they do it is with
delicatessen knives.
A machetes is too big, and
it hacks at things.
But delicatessen roast
beef knives.
They're about this long.
They're real thin.
You've got people out
there with these.
And guess who does
it all today?
Latin Americans, I
would say mostly.
They're probably
mostly Mexican.
Now, they have turned out
to be hard workers.
They want to send
money back home.
And it's terrible work.
There's no machine you
can bring into a
Christmas tree farm.
You just have to go through
all those prickly--
well, they're like
thorns almost.
RICK KLEFFEL: Well, you give us
a great vision of a Miami
where most of the population
is not white,
where it's run by Cubans.
And you also have a lot
of fun with the media
in this, and art.
You do some fun things
with art.
Is a really a no-hands
art movement?
TOM WOLFE: Yes, there is.
I'll tell you, it's
a very powerful
movement in terms of--
RICK KLEFFEL: Really?
TOM WOLFE: --the art critics.
Jeff Koons--
you may know his work.
He builds-- pff.
"Builds." He has elves build
45-foot-high bunny rabbits,
with various vegetation growing
on them to give them a
kind of look like fur.
He doesn't touch that,
of course.
RICK KLEFFEL: It sounds
like a giant Chia Pet.
TOM WOLFE: Yeah.
He also had some photographs.
I think he actually
married her.
A very famous Italian prostitute
called "La
Cicciolina".
And she was famous because she
had messed up somebody's
political career.
And they were together.
And he would have photographs
taken of himself and La
Cicciolina exploring
about every orifice
in the human body.
I mean these were unbelievable
scenes.
These were sent to elves in
Switzerland, who created them
out of glass.
They're kind of like Limoges.
RICK KLEFFEL: So that's real?
TOM WOLFE: That's real.
Absolutely.
RICK KLEFFEL: Oh my god.
TOM WOLFE: And they fetch--
A, he never touched
the camera.
And I doubt if he even mails
them to the elves.
He has people who
do that for him.
These objects are
three-dimensional and glass.
But so what that he didn't
touch, that he had nothing to
do with it?
They sell for fantastic
prices.
1.7 million for him and La
Cicciolina in glass.
It is not uncommon.
RICK KLEFFEL: Did
you attend the
Superbowl of art criticism?
TOM WOLFE: Oh, I did.
RICK KLEFFEL: Did you have
an AA to show you
which ones were valuable?
TOM WOLFE: Oh, actually,
I did.
RICK KLEFFEL: So this is an
event where people go in.
It's millionaires lining
up, as you
describe it, like maggots.
TOM WOLFE: Well, the most
noted ones were actually
billionaires.
There were 12 in line
when I went there.
I had to wangle my way
to be in that line.
It's the most privileged line at
the Miami Art Basel, which
is an international art show
of supposedly serious art.
And these--
and I'm not kidding--
billionaires get in line.
And these are people who are not
young, but they're wearing
basketball shoes so that they
can get into the booth of the
artist that they really
want first.
And the fact that they're going
to rush in and pay $17
million for something
is no problem.
That is not a deterrent.
RICK KLEFFEL: This is Black
Friday for millionaires.
TOM WOLFE: Yeah.
I couldn't believe it, so I
wrote it, to make sure I
didn't forget it.
It's an extraordinary thing.
But all it they all have, as
you alluded, advisers they
call AAs who tell them
what they like.
You like that.
And it's just no telling what
that may turn out to be.
Oh, there's also tenure art.
We mustn't forget tenure art.
T-E-N-U-R-E. These are artists
who do conceptual pieces, such
as one that I saw, and
actually rather
enjoyed, in a way.
The artist--
"artist"--
had a heavy chain, the length
was about this long.
On either end, he had attached
big polyurethane bags filled
with vegetables.
And the first part of the piece
of art is you come out,
and he lays the chain on
the top of a pond.
Naturally, it sinks right
to the bottom.
And then he invites you back in
about two months, and you
go out to the pond.
And now, the vegetables have
all rotted, filling the
polyurethane bags with gas.
And now the chain is floating
on the surface.
And I will admit, it's pretty
wonderful to, if you saw it
sink the first time.
But now this, obviously, cannot
be sold to anybody.
Another piece I saw an action
was a pig roast.
And the Caja China-- that's
a Cuban grill.
And the whole piece of the
artwork was seeing them
prepare the pig, and seeing
the pig roasting.
and we're talking about
an 8-hour show now.
And then afterwards, everyone
who's there eats the pig.
That's another piece
of tenure art.
The idea is, if you do enough
of these things that attract
attention, and maybe get you
into some of the magazines,
you have a pretty good shot at
joining the fine arts faculty
of a good university.
And if you can hang in there for
six years-- that's all it
takes now--
that's tenure.
You have tenure.
And when you retire, you have
a pretty level pension.
Depending on your needs
and wants and desires,
your life is set.
RICK KLEFFEL: I don't need
much more and two bags of
vegetables and a chain link.
TOM WOLFE: It's been done.
It's been done.
The important thing is
it hasn't been done.
Well, I've given up.
I found this all great,
because for a
writer, it's all gold.
It's absolutely gold.
One of the main terms at Yale
today in the fine arts
department is de-skilled art.
The idea is that all
of this drawing--
[AUDIO CUTS OUT]
TOM WOLFE: --three dimensional
effects, it's very--
[AUDIO CUTS OUT]
TOM WOLFE: --the reader, that
person who's done in an
outline, that person
doesn't exist.
And the three dimension.
Come on, touch the damn thing.
It's just absolutely flat.
That's deception.
So what you have to do is have
honest art, which is
de-skilled.
You've just got to take
the skill out of it.
This I really shouldn't
say, but I think
that describes Picasso.
RICK KLEFFEL: Well, he shows
up in your book, too.
TOM WOLFE: He does pop in.
I have said this before, so
I shouldn't repeat it.
But if I couldn't--
I'm talking about me.
I'm not talking about
some journal--
RICK KLEFFEL: Don't worry.
YouTube's going to repeat
it for you.
TOM WOLFE: If I could not draw
better than Picasso, what I
would do is create a movement
called cubism.
And so that they don't think I'm
trying to draw a skilled
face, I put both eyes on one
side of the head, and then the
nose goes out somewhere
that noses never go.
See, the problem with Picasso
was he left art school because
at 15, he felt there
was nothing more
they could teach him.
Unfortunately, it was that next
some semester they began
to teach anatomy and the third
dimension, perspective.
So he had to do the
best he can.
Look at early.
He had more or less realistic in
the so-called Blue Period.
Take a look at the fingers.
They look like a clump of a
asparagus bought at the
grocery store.
They're all the same length.
If he can, he hides them.
Matisse also could
not do hands.
And sometime, if you're just
rummaging through a book of
art, and you come to Matisse,
just look at all the hands
that are stuck behind
the back.
I just think it's wonderful.
People think I knock art.
I don't.
I never make a single
aesthetic judgment.
I just tell how it happened.
I swear.
RICK KLEFFEL: Here, let me
help you with this guy.
Now in this book,
we have a great
look at American culture.
And one of the things you give
us are how any single act that
any of us does can be turned
into a dozen different acts
depending on who's telling the
story, and how it's been told.
At the center of this book is
Nestor Camacho, who does
something that seems, at the
moment, quite valiant and
incredible.
But in the aftermath, it just
gets spun 10 different ways by
10 different news
organizations.
Talk about putting us in those
news perspectives.
Did you intern yourself, so
to speak, with the Cuban
newspaper, and the American
newspaper, and the bloggers,
and all the other people that
you talk about in the book?
TOM WOLFE: Fortunately, I
spent 10 years on the--
I guess it was fortunate--
10 years on newspapers.
I felt I kind of knew the
drill from the newspaper
perspective.
In this particular case that
Rick's referring to, my
central character's name
is Nestor Camacho.
Nobody ever understands Cuban
first names, males
particularly.
Nestor was a great hero the
Trojan wars, but it drives him
crazy, everybody, in Americano,
calls him
"Nest-er." It ends in E-R.
And I'll point out,
it's very unusual.
He's on the Miami
Marine Patrol.
Beyond the patrol is a step
up from walking a beat or
something, or driving a beat.
And he is in the probation
period.
So on this safe boat,
they're called--
wackiest looking boat you've
ever seen, but they go 45
miles an hour on the water.
They're for saving
people and boats.
So he's on with two Anglos.
I have to say, the Cubans
would never use
the word like gringo.
They will say Americano if
they're speaking among
themselves.
In general, it's Anglos
and Latinos.
At the beginning of Florida--
Southern Florida's the only
place on the face of the earth
where anybody was ever
called a Latina, a
Latino, or an Anglo.
And an Anglo is of
European origin.
But if he's not completely
white, he's not an Anglo.
It all has to do with
skin color.
Anyway, there are these two
Anglos, or Americanos, who
outrank him on the boat.
He is the third man, the young
man, he's on probation.
And they're having a
conversation, and he says
something that sounds
to the two
Americanos as rather uppity.
I'm thinking of the Sergeant,
or the man in chief.
And Nestor's on probation,
and he goes, oh my god.
This is bad, if I get washed
out of probation.
So they are called to a
situation in which there's a
Cuban refugee atop
a schooner mast.
So he's up about 75, 80 feet.
The boat is stopped right
near a causeway.
Miami has lots of causeways
go across Biscayne Bay.
And they've stopped, because
they're not sure that the mass
will clear the bridge.
And so they're trying to
figure out what to do.
And this Cuban refugee, who
has obviously paid about
$5,000, is brought
in by a cigarette
boat, they're called.
Those are the really fast,
small, good-looking boats.
70 miles an hour.
RICK KLEFFEL: Did
you ride on one?
TOM WOLFE: I would have gladly
done it, but I didn't ride on
one of those.
I did ride on the marine
patrol boat.
RICK KLEFFEL: Oh, really?
TOM WOLFE: Yeah.
Oh, yeah.
I'd never heard of it myself.
RICK KLEFFEL: Sounds like fun.
TOM WOLFE: It was.
That thing is really
hell on wheels.
But it's the safe boat.
It wasn't going to turn over.
So they get there, and it turns
out that if a Cuban
touches American soil, or
anything edifice that's
jutting out from it, like a
jetty or a bridge, he cannot
be sent back to Cuba.
If he's done something bad,
he can be prosecuted.
But he cannot be sent back.
But if you don't do that, you're
called a wetfoot, and
you're sent back.
Now, this fellow he apparently
wasn't--
well, he was a little bit
deranged or confused.
And he sees this ladder that
goes up, and he figures it
goes up to a dock.
In fact, it goes onto the
deck of a schooner.
If you're on a schooner,
you're still a wetfoot.
Even if the schooner is owned
by the governor of Florida,
you're in bad luck.
So this Camacho speaks
Spanish.
Like a lot of second generation
Cubans, he speaks
12-year-old Spanish.
When they get a little older,
they'd rather see American
television, learn
American ways.
Their parents may be
kind of stuck--
RICK KLEFFEL: Sure.
It's easier to be immersed.
And then the immigrant has
climbed up the mast, trying to
maybe jump onto that causeway.
TOM WOLFE: Yeah.
And he was a little frightened
by the reaction of the owners
of the ship.
So he goes up on this mast.
He's 75 feet up in the air.
And so the two Anglos, or two
American crewman who outrank
him said, you speak Spanish.
Go on up there and tell
him to come down.
He's tying up traffic
on the causeway.
It's just a block of traffic.
Because he's threatened with
being washed out of probation,
he doesn't dare tell them that
he cannot speak anything above
12-year-old Spanish.
So he's very powerfully built.
Incidentally, I don't know if
anybody here, any male who
really wants to be powerfully
built, but you cannot top rope
climbing without using
your legs.
RICK KLEFFEL: That's a big
theme of this book.
Get out there and rope
climb, guys.
TOM WOLFE: To climb ropes,
you can't use your legs.
Can't use your legs.
Anyway, he does this, because
the quickest way to go up,
it's much quicker to go up
without using your legs, if
you have the strength, than
to stop or use them.
So he climbs all the way
up, and he gets within
10 feet of the guy.
And he realizes if you
are fleeing from a
credible threat in Cuba--
that's the word, a
credible threat--
they're not going
to arrest you.
Miami police never arrest
an illegal immigrants.
They leave that up to the
federal government.
They have enough people to make
enemies with as it is.
So he's practically up to the
guy, and he doesn't know the
word for threat.
And this may seem strange,
because it's the same word as
in English.
He also does not know the word
"credible," or credible.
Because it's just not a word
a 12-year-old uses.
RICK KLEFFEL: Sure.
TOM WOLFE: He's actually
26 in this scene.
So he gets up there, and
he doesn't know what
to say to the guy.
So he starts flashing
the peace sign.
And that only frightens--
they could be devil's horns.
Who knows what he's flashing
at the guy.
So he doesn't respond-- in fact,
he tries to get up out
of this little bosun chair that
he's nestled in at the
top of the mast.
And he gets up, and he starts
trying to get away by going
down the jib.
RICK KLEFFEL: The triangulation,
right?
To the bow.
TOM WOLFE: That cable that
goes to the bow.
And he's not strong enough,
this fellow from Cuba.
And so Nestor, my friend, climbs
down, hand-over-hand
down, and then wraps his legs
around the this guy.
He's not very big, maybe
120, 130 pounds.
And carries him down, all the
way down the jib line, which
leads you, actually,
into the water.
Because it juts out
over the prow.
And they fall into the water.
The guy fights him.
He's fighting him.
He think he's going to take him
and turn him in and send
him back to Cuba.
And at first, his police
brethren say, my god--
Police don't use the
word "bravery." Jet
pilots don't either.
They'll say, that was an
unacceptable level of risk in
that operation.
[LAUGHTER]
TOM WOLFE: That's about
as close as they get.
But anyway, they were all proud
of him, the police--
who are mostly Cuban.
so.
He's really happy, and
then he goes home.
It's now after midnight.
It was the four to
midnight shift.
And he expects to get all
this adulation at home.
And instead, he walks in,
here's his father.
His arms crossed like this.
RICK KLEFFEL: "Aye, Carmillo."
TOM WOLFE: Aye, Carmillo
Camacho.
That's the last name.
I and your woman who became your
mother spent 12 days at
sea on a homemade dinghy.
We had to make it an apartment
because the block wardens
would have detected it if we
had tried to do it outside.
We almost died 100 times.
We finally made it, thank
god, to Key West.
We came aland, and we all live--
and your grandparents,
too, who were living
in that house.
And happy to do this.
You've drag our name
through the mud.
Poor guy.
"They ordered me!" Ah, yes,
they ordered people in
Germany, too.
He couldn't get away
with that, they
ordered me to do it.
And then everybody turns
against him.
RICK KLEFFEL: This is a
book that is really
involved with guilt.
There's a lot of guilt
in this book.
You really have a lot
of fun with guilt.
You know, I've just got to say
that you had a lot of fun in
this book, didn't you?
Writing this book, putting
this together.
You must have spent
a lot of time.
It sounds like this
is a book that you
had a good time writing.
TOM WOLFE: Oh, no.
I've never had a good time
writing anything.
I think it's the hardest
work in the world.
The only thing that gets you
through is that, maybe
somebody will applaud
when it's over.
RICK KLEFFEL: Well, now, these
people are going to applaud.
But I think some of them--
TOM WOLFE: No, you don't
have to applaud.
You haven't read the book.
RICK KLEFFEL: Some of them might
have some questions.
Does anybody out there have any
questions for Mr. Tom Wolfe?
AUDIENCE: Thank you
for coming.
Aspiring novelist.
Written one really bad book.
I'm hoping that the next
one isn't as bad.
Any advice for going from short
stories up to something
all encompassing and substantial
as this?
TOM WOLFE: Well, first of all,
you can't make a living on
short stories.
It's very hard.
AUDIENCE: That's why I'm
a software engineer.
[LAUGHTER]
TOM WOLFE: It's very hard.
But in my case, what gets me the
point of writing something
that long is I will hear
of a certainly milieu.
And except for my book on the
astronauts, is always been
things I heard through
conversation.
That way, I figure
it'll be new.
If it's new for me, it's
probably new for most people.
And wherever that's happening,
I will go.
My motto is "leave the
building." I'll go there and
try to just learn as
much as I can.
Like the man from Mars.
I don't know what
you're doing.
I'm really interested.
And it's true.
That's what I'm like
when I'm there.
And I think it's important--
and this may sound like--
but it's not hot air.
It's important to have
a concept of life.
I really believe that.
In my case, it's the theory of
status as was developed by Max
Weber, German sociologist.
But there are people who have
done great things with, let's
say, Christianity.
There's so many pieces to great
literature that come out
of a belief.
Marxism has not done badly, that
many of the good writers
in America in the 1930s and
the '40s were Marxists.
The thing about Marxism
that's good--
not much else is--
is that it forces you to
recognize class distinctions.
And class is not a very
accurate word
in the United States.
But still, it forces
you do it.
And you suddenly become
conscious of a working class.
You become conscious
of a bourgeoisie.
And oddly, they never
get after the
plutocrats very much.
I don't know why.
Sometime, look at some
Marxist literature.
They kind of leave them alone.
But the bourgeoisie--
But it is a way of noticing how
society is put together.
Max Weber, I think, made
the Marxist breakdown--
he wasn't a Marxist, but
much more subtle.
Because I think most of us feel
that we are in a certain
status group, and that we live
by a set of values that are
natural to this group, which,
if chiseled in stone by God,
would make you supreme.
Not you, your group.
The essential thing
is the group.
And in a case like mine,
I'm in a group
of people who write.
I include even journalists
in the
group, and serious writers.
But then, I also grew up
in Richmond, Virginia.
And every now and then, without
my knowing it--
I'll give a good example.
When these two Virginians--
Pat Robinson the evangelist,
and the evangelist from
Lynchburg, Virginia,
Jerry Falwell--
When they came out protesting,
at a really key point early in
the game, same-sex marriage
as an absolute violation.
Oh, it was worse than that.
It was different from that.
They blamed September 11,
2001 on homosexuality.
And my god, they were torn
to bits by [INAUDIBLE].
And I said, wait a minute!
These two guys are not bad.
Pat Robinson went to the
college I went to.
Maybe they're wrong.
But they're not evil.
Many of us have a duel.
We'll find ourselves being loyal
to our backgrounds, when
we'd never even thought
about it.
But there tend to
be these groups.
People who are in the arts,
believe me, they have a real
different set of values.
RICK KLEFFEL: We have another
question over there.
LOGAN: Hi, my name is Logan.
Thank you so much for coming.
It's an honor to
have you here.
TOM WOLFE: Well,
you're welcome.
LOGAN: As someone who's spent
his career interested in
class, and observing class in
America, I was wondering if
you could speak a little bit
about this election cycle.
I feel like that's something
that's really come up a lot.
And even in the last six months,
and before that with
Occupy Wall Street, it's
very relevant.
So I'd love to hear your
opinion about that.
TOM WOLFE: They've tried, and
the press has tried to help,
too, to turn this into
a class election.
The 1% against the 99%.
Somewhere, the lower
class disappeared.
Everyone talks about
the middle class.
What's this middle class?
I don't get it.
Whatever you want it to be.
It includes,
RICK KLEFFEL: Tyrannosaurus
rex, brontosaurus--
TOM WOLFE: Anybody who is
employed even as an intern is
part of the middle class now.
And on both sides, we hear--
Mitt Romney and his
first rally I saw.
I mean, my god, are his
beginnings humble.
Obama, the same way.
Oh my god, are his beginnings
humble.
And he's come up from nowhere.
So has Mitt Romney.
This is not a sign of a
class-ridden society.
If your credentials have to
include failure, obscurity,
that's not a class-ridden
society.
In England--
probably the same thing's
true now--
when people go to visit the
poor, they dress up.
In a way, I suppose, to
show them what they
could become someday.
In this country, if we have a
contractor coming over to do
some demolition in the house,
everybody takes off their
jackets, their neckties, the
shirts they put on, their
turtleneck sweaters.
They don't want to look wrong
when these working men arrive.
Of course, the working men say,
oh, these poor people,
they're reduced to rags.
[LAUGHTER]
TOM WOLFE: Thomas Jefferson
took care of class in this
country, and it has
never reappeared.
When America was finally
recognized by England, and the
British ambassador arrives for
this historic meeting in the
White House, he's wearing some
kind of military cap from god
knows when.
He has a ceremonial sword.
It's about this long,
but it's a sword.
All sorts of trappings.
Jefferson meets him in
his bedroom slippers.
It wasn't the bedroom.
But he comes out in his bedroom
slippers to the great
portico as you go in
the White House.
And dinner, here's the British
ambassador and his wife, and
all these dignitaries, mostly
American, who are there.
And he says, well,
this dinner's
going to be pell mell.
They say, what do you
mean, pell mell?
He said, well, if you see a seat
you like, and you're near
it, take it.
And they found that all the
tables were round so that
there was no head
of the table.
This was all thought
out by Jefferson.
And the only person who's taken
to a seat, and assigned
seat, was the wife
of ambassador.
And Jefferson seated
her next to him.
Everybody else, including
the ambassador, had
to rush to a seat.
And if it was occupied,
well, it was too bad.
It was this pell mell system.
And these things were all done
by Jefferson to say, that old
stuff is over.
We are not in Europe.
He made John Marshall, the Chief
Justice of the United
States take the ribbons--
he had noticed in Europe, the
Chief Judge would often have
these golden ribbons across
the black robe--
he made Marshall take his off.
We're not going to
have that stuff.
RICK KLEFFEL: What we are
going to have is this.
An America that has gone
"Back to Blood," and
YouTube, as it were.
TOM WOLFE: I explained that I
don't mind horror fiction when
people are thinking
of buying my book.
But it's not wet blood.
It's bloodlines.
RICK KLEFFEL: Bloodlines.
TOM WOLFE: I should
warn you of that.
RICK KLEFFEL: Ladies and
gentlemen, we have been graced
to have with us Tom Wolfe.
He is the author of "The
Electric Kool-Aid Acid Test,"
"The Right Stuff," and his
newest novel is "Back to
Blood." Thank you
for joining me.
And thank you for
joining me, Tom.
It was a pleasure.
TOM WOLFE: Thanks.
I enjoyed this.
Thank you very much.